hello folks welcome to
rational science
great day for physics terrible day for
mathematical so-called physics
and we're going to be doing
what pendulums today what is a pendulum
and before we do that we're going to go
into some subjects related to extinction
as we usually do
and so let's start with this headline
that came out
here it is
world races to contain new covid thread
the omicron variant
uh it says that the article said said in
announcing new travel restrictions he
president biden
told reporters i've decided that we're
going to be
cautious
so get ready for a new round of um
restrictions
and uh it makes me kind of wonder you
know i mean
this is the time of the year where
people get
regular flu
okay
and so yeah i expected people to get
colds and so on i usually well not
usually i haven't had one for maybe a
couple years but i
regularly or periodically
get um
get flus and colds and so on and usually
it's this time of the year if it's not
in october november and december it's
maybe at the end of the
winner you know
around um
what is it uh april thereabouts and if i
don't get in those two times of the year
i usually don't get it at all
and so for them to say look we have the
kobe just when the flu comes in
and it's kind of suspicious
at least for me you know
and uh that's what i you know this is my
take on on covet and yeah i do clarify
that i did get the shots and i got the
shots merely because i was going to
travel to south america
and i'm glad i did
because you know you don't imagine all
the hassle you get because of this covet
thing
and they're just going to tighten the
screws now i mean right now here in
germany um
you can't even take the public
transportation unless you come with your
coveted shots you know documented
your little passport your visa
to go to the streets
and uh as i understand it also the uh
you know these uh food stores especially
and malls if if you still remember what
a mall was
uh they're going to be requiring these
things as well
and so this is my take on it okay i'm
saying that uh
these are the foreign against the pros
and cons uh i'm saying that it seems
like there is some kind of uh bug out
there and the reason i think that is
that you know i think the enemies of the
united states such as
you know uh cuba or north korea they
would not cooperate with the united
states on something like this
you know they wouldn't go ahead and tell
their public oh yeah
we've got this coveted thing so you got
to get the shots and you got to stay
indoors and all that kind of stuff
no you would think that at least the
enemy countries would not follow
uh the rich people in the united states
so that gives me an idea that there is a
bug out there okay
uh on the other hand uh these are the
things that i've got that make me wonder
okay
one is all the profiting that's going on
with this covid
uh all the control you know the fact
that they make you wear a mask and now
what you need to carry carry a passport
on the streets or otherwise the gestapo
will stop you and say hey where's your
covet shot
and take you in or or find you or
whatever
and then
the fact that we have these new strains
specifically at the time that uh you
know that it's it's flu season and the
question is
is this just an ordinary flu or is this
uh
you know something um
that uh they've invented
i mean especially the the new strands
you know that makes you kind of wonder
uh
is there something going on out there
and you might say well what could be
going on okay
well
i'm just gonna
you know uh
shoot the bull around okay and uh i'm
just gonna propose let's assume the rich
folk have already figured out that they
can't solve the world's problems
economic problems
okay so maybe they're just looking to
extend
our lives as much as possible you know
and maybe this is one way of doing it
you know uh getting people under control
telling them you know scaring them with
this
covet thing let's just assume i'm making
an assumption i'm not saying i believe
this i'm i'm just making an assumption
let's let's assume that this is a theory
you know that this could be going on
that if they know it's all going down
the drain they might say well how can we
extend it well one way to extend it is
to say well yeah you know there's this
bug out there you got to cover your face
you got to stay at home you can't travel
you know all this kind of stuff
meanwhile they make some money or some
of them make some money others lose
because the restaurants
hotels are losing money
airlines
but it could happen something like that
that that would be one of the
ways that i can imagine
um that
they could create this story this fib
but then again uh you know i don't think
north korea cuba russia china they would
all
you know shake hands with the u.s
government okay and europe
uh so
again
just a theory okay
not that i believe it but it is
something like that might be going on in
the in the background
okay something i talked about the other
day in the news this week
mr assange what would we do without mr
assange what a slick guy
says u.s stonewall's probe into security
firm they're allegedly spied on a sign
for a cia's a spanish judge
okay so they put him in the news again
and yeah this guy's in the news every
day
okay and the question is whether he's
real
and i'm saying he ain't
not not by a long stretch okay this guy
can't be for real and here let me show
you some proof some evidence okay this
is proof evidence that assange
is a u.s government operation okay here
you see him with his wife stella running
around outside the embassy one in
2017. now if you remember correctly a
couple years earlier uh they had all the
bodies surrounding the ecuadorian
embassy they wouldn't you know they they
said they might they had the power to go
in there
and drag them out and the oas here in
the uh in the western world they had a
big powwow saying how dare they how can
the british think that they can go into
the embassy and drag them out that's a
violation of the diplomatic
protocol etc etc
and here a couple years later this guy's
running around the streets of london
now where were the bobbies when we
needed them here i mean this is when the
mi6 and the mi5 should have gone in
there and arrested him
what's this guy doing on the streets and
then you know this thing about killing
him and murdering him that they're
spreading out now look at the bottom uh
right
picture there where it says the guardian
you had the bobbies and he was and this
guy assange was talking from the window
you know out to the public that was
gathered there
i mean you know if they really wanted to
kill him
this was an easier shot than jfk
you know
they could have shot him down right
there and you know if he's such a a
criminal
i don't think that anybody would have
you know lost any
sleep over it right
so uh no this guy this guy for sure is
not for real
but you know some people believe them
and believe this other bozo ed snowden
which the united states created
and yeah uh
they have to do these operations
remember you know the united states
spends over 80 billion dollars a year
in um
intelligence
overall
and
people say well yeah we have to defend
ourselves against china and against
russia and now the number one enemy of
the u.s government is not either russia
or china it's the american people okay
it's the people of the united states
those are the ones they have to have
under control because if you don't have
those under control forget about china
and russia okay you got a problem right
there in front of you
so those are the people that have to
lead by the nose so one fellow says here
says
how is the u.s government responsible
for assange and snowden having a public
profile
okay
do the governments control the media
are the people who work in the news
media honest but dumb or are they uh
actual info agents
you know like all of them or what are we
talking about here and what are those
that own the media okay
and yeah uh
i'll just give you my five cents worth
uh the united states is the country
that has the least
um
freedom of press
okay it's the one that has the least
freedom of press it has to be first of
all because it's the number one empire
and so it has to put all the controls in
place to make sure that you know the
right information reaches the public
and especially on things that matter
okay it has to be on things that matter
you know if uh one person out there you
know says uh okay we have this hollywood
couple joe blow and uh susie q and
they're separating they're getting a
divorce and so you're gonna have all
these different opinions about them one
guy say well it's his fault and the
other person's gonna say no it's her
fault and they're gonna have opinions a
million nobody cares about that that's
dumb blonde kind of stuff you know small
talk so there you can have a million
opinions you can also have democrats
against republicans and they're gonna
you know they have their newspapers
their outlets and they're gonna shoot uh
you know mud at each other
but it's when things count things that
are important where you where you test
freedom of the press
those are the ones that are important
you know jfk's assassination 9 11
and these two bozos assange
and snowden that's where it counts
and then you find eerily right you find
unanimity
you find that uh all newspapers all tv
stations in the united states
all radio stations
all of them 150 percent of them
you know jfk is a lot of people down
they have blogs and they even put videos
out there but the official version is
what spread throughout the main channels
right out there and what do they say
well they say that oh you're a
conspiracist we have all these
conspiracies you know these nuts out
there and they believe that jfk was
assassinated by the u.s government can
you believe that
you know these people are nuts are crazy
that's how they treat you you know and
uh 911 oh we have all these conspiracies
out there
and assange and snowden 100 50
unanimity not one newspaper not one tv
station not one radio station in the
entire united states even suspects
even considers either even ponders or
theorizes that
maybe just maybe this could be a u.s
government operation
you would think that at least one
newspaper
one tv station one radio station
uh would say hey you know just maybe you
know just uh let's uh
let's um just
try a theory there right not one of them
everyone has
gone in the same direction
and yeah here you see why part
part of the reason why okay here's this
fellow and his name is rupert murdoch
and he owns uh
practically all the news in the united
states
billionaire businessman media tycoon and
investor and you can see there how the
blogs portray him as you know a guy who
dominates the politicians and he's a
the murdered octopus
yeah because um
he controls a lot of stuff
he's the puppeteer okay
through his company news corp he is the
owner of hundreds of local national
international publishing outlets around
the world uh there you have uk australia
us okay some of the things he owns
with that net worth of 22 billion as of
28th july 2021
marduk is the 31st richest person in the
united states and the 71st
richest in the world
okay so uh yeah a good old rupert uh he
owns a lot but i mean you know who do
you think he goes around with well he he
goes around with his buddies other
people who own the uh the media and they
all think the same way
and so you know and the things that
matter
you know like
911 jfk assassination assange and
snowden they play ball
they play ball they're not gonna oppose
the u.s government because now you're
not talking about republican against
democrat now you're talking about 250
years of democracy going down the drain
if people even suspect that that could
be the case
and so you have to drive it in and the
new generations a lot of them don't do
research and they just buy the official
version because it's 90 percent of the
word that's out there
so you think a lot of them are going to
say oh yeah 9 11 was done by george bush
no of course not they're going to go out
there and say oh there's this guy bin
laden who apparently burned the
buildings and that's all they know
and you know
and on top of they have youtube wiping
out videos they wiped out three of my
videos
you need to be over 150 years old to re
to listen to the uh 9 11 anthem that i
put out there
so
they blocked it so you know you you got
all this uh going on and who who's doing
that well it's all these rich people who
say hey get rid of all the youtube
videos that are talking against 9 11 and
just put the ones that talk in favor
let's just put i mean why would they do
that unless they're trying to prepare
the new generations just to repeat the
party lie
okay so yeah the united states is number
one in um
uh
in uh free in least freedom of the press
now china and russia you know they don't
have very much freedom of the press but
people are aware of it because they're
so
uh
they're so blunt in the way they do it
you know
they're not subtle
so everybody knows the chinese
communist party or the cuban communist
party is just going to put a lot of
propaganda and so obvious so people
know it even in the country they're very
much aware of that but in the united
states people actually believe the news
they say no we have a democratic country
we have free press here and that's why
they believe it because the united
states much more subtle than the way it
does it and in that sense yeah it is the
least
freedom of the press country in the
world
okay here's uh
another comment along the scene these
same lines it might be in american
interest to start a world war
whoa
to unify its population and prevent a
civil war
okay politicians have done that in the
past where they create a diversion okay
uh
so that people stop thinking about
one thing and instead concentrate on
another
except that i would say that a um
you know a uh
world war
is probably much more dangerous than uh
when he says there are race war within
the united states
so i don't know and the question for you
is will there ever be a civil war in the
united states is is this ramping up are
we having to write against the left uh
killing each other
you know maybe on the streets uh one
group kills someone from the other side
yeah that might happen will that uh blow
over into a full-scale civil war where
military people who
you know command
forces take sides and
shoot against each other
you know i don't think so uh but you
know again people have different
opinions about these things
okay uh another
around the war issue
we have a lot of war stuff today
the war doesn't put people at work
well it's absolute nonsense uh bill uh
because i said that that doesn't put
people to work i don't get that okay uh
first because we are already at war
the world is at war or rather several
wars in different countries at the same
time yeah that's not a war a world war
we were talking about world war three
here uh the big guys
and i mean the big guys confronting big
guys not
uh using you know all these um
tiny countries where they meet and the
forces that fight are the local ones and
they just feed them weapons that's
different than you know a head-on clash
between
you know the two monsters out there
that's very different okay so
i just want to put it in the right
context this perennial state of war
gives work to billions of individuals
yeah and again he took that out of
context because the context is that in
world war ii like you see there
uh women especially came out of the
houses you know especially the young
girls and they started working at the
factories they had jobs and a lot of
them came out of the houses and started
working men they went out to europe and
got killed or or asia and got killed
and uh
but what happened was all these people
were working in the armaments business
what is armaments that's known as
manufacturing okay they work in industry
and i'm saying that if there is a war
now
people are not going to be working by
the gazillions
in the manufacturing
segment of the economy
that's what i'm saying
and so yeah they're going to continue
working what they are now in fact i
don't even think they're going to be
working in what they're working now
because we have all these killer
satellites out there that the first
thing they'll wipe out will will be the
uh the satellites
and you won't have any internet
and if you don't have any energy net
forget about
guiding the missiles that's the least of
the problems the big problem will be
that they wiped out all the money on the
planet
they wiped out all the money because all
the money is on the internet oh my
bitcoins oh they're gone
yeah
yeah how many did you have
yeah internet is very frail you know if
the satellite goes down that's it for
the internet guys you know no
communication and suddenly you're as
poor as or as rich
as uh bill gates okay so keep that in
mind you know the internet is everything
right now and all the jobs depend on the
internet now as well you wipe out the
internet you wiped out what close to
eighty percent of the jobs
in the united states in the world okay
lots of jobs depend on the internet now
so we don't want to mess with those
satellites okay please don't touch them
but now we've got the killer satellite
so yeah we got the
we got what we needed the antidote to
the satellites to the internet so if you
ever were upset about the internet maybe
the russians will help you
okay here we have the fourth industrial
revolution
what the hell is that plan design and in
progress
okay that's being um uh
stimulated
uh spread out by
some rich people and here you have a few
of them okay they're famous because
they're behind this fourth industrial
revolution and you have this uh other
fella who is i've been tracking for many
years now ray kurzweil and he says the
singularity a point where the
development of technology becomes so
fast that humanity will no longer be
able to keep up with it okay the
singularity remember that comes out of
mathematics right uh black hole has
singularity at its center what's a
what's a particle it's a singularity
everything's a singularity what's an
event singularity a point in space time
etc yeah the singularity in other words
is the moment a.i you know artificial
intelligence begins to evolve without us
okay
so these people are all saying oh we're
very close to the singularity in fact
that's what kurzweil has been saying for
many years saying we're very close to
the singularity to the point where the
ais take off and we can't control them
anymore now they run the count the world
you know because now they can invent
stuff and and create stuff
and they're smarter than us at that
point and so now their intelligence
grows exponentially
and they can uh think
things exponentially well our tiny
brains they can't keep up well these
guys tiny brains i'm sorry
they can't keep up so what is this uh
fourth industrial revolution let's find
out you know i want to know what this
revolution is all about because i must
have missed it or i'm missing it and one
of the two and here it is the fourth
industrial revolution
uh the first one was water and steam
power to mechanize production okay and
you're talking about maybe the late uh
1700s early 1800s where they invented
steam right and they started driving
some of the engines with steams
you heard the steam locomotive the steam
in
ships etc okay
and then second one was electric power
to create mass production and you know
that started probably in the
late
19th century for sure most of the 20th
century you know we started putting
electricity behind things okay
you know a refrigerators um washing
machines
television you know we didn't have any
of that in the 19th century that started
all in the 20th century
and uh the third one uh again i must
have missed this one because i i i only
recognize
uh the first revolution the only
revolution which was that second one
there the electric power well the com
really both of them first and second
okay but here it says electronics and
information technology to automate
production
that was the third one
okay
and the fourth one what is this fourth
one all about says the digital
revolution the digital revolution
characterized by fusion of technologies
that is blurring the lines between the
physical digital and biological spheres
well the first comment i want to say is
that you know revolution requires masses
of people that's known as a revolution
until that happens you don't have a
revolution you need masses of people and
so one of the issues there is whether um
these things are going to put
masses of workers to work okay that's
that's the first one i'm saying yeah you
got to look at
but
uh the question is what you know if if
you don't put people to work in
manufacturing
into industry do you have a revolution
you know these people talking about
minor changes cosmetic changes
in the world of industry
but it was industry all along all the
way from the
18th century all the way to the 21st
century it was all industry
manufacturing
and that's become smaller and smaller
and smaller
in the last 200 years today in the
advanced nations it's anywhere between
15 and 20 percent of their gdp and of
their workforce most
most people work about eighty percent or
near eighty percent
work in uh
services primarily today and moving
closer to
uh
internet services
you know ads uh entertainment we're in
the bs world now we're producing nothing
and uh manufacturing is becoming a
smaller percent of gdp and a small
percent uh percentage of the workforce
and again i don't think even a war is
going to put people to work in
manufacturing because they do have first
of all they have all the equipment they
need out there
for the most part they're all they're
all prepared for for the next war but
even if they need to ramp up it's going
to be done by what the ais their robots
you know
we have um
machines producing uh
you know the the new bombs and so on a
lot of the parts and so on
so it's not going to put people to work
and so when i talk about
a war not putting people to work i'm
talking about a war putting people to
work in manufacturing
that's what i'm talking about because
that's what
solved the problem uh
for what happened in the 30s which was
the depression era
you know uh people couldn't find work
and things were pretty lousy the war
helped everybody help
germany uh as well as the united states
it helped uh russia for sure
helped
england and france
except that they were immediately
conquered by hitler but you know after
the destruction occurred after five
years six years there
you know
manufacturing ramped up it was a
manufacturing age at its highest it was
the golden age of manufacturing
and yeah after all that happened you
know we moved into services and now what
is manufacturing today we have all the
goods we need
tangible goods i mean
you probably have a house or rent one
you have a roof over your head you
probably have a fridge you probably have
an oven you know
you know
what is it kitchen
a washing machine a dryer
everybody's got one of those pretty much
at least in the advanced nations and he
who doesn't have it in the poor nation
wants to have it
you know and that's not going to drive
because these are the poor people yeah
and it's not going to drive a demand to
such a
point where you have manufacturing grow
again no manufacturing manufacturing's
over we're done with manufacturing and
with the
mode uh you know the uh
family type
which is related to the manufacturer
which is the nuclear family you know mom
popping kids that's over as well
we're now in the services
services is the single person the
bachelor or the homosexual people who
don't produce children essentially
you know in any way you look at it
you're not going to be producing
children everybody's moved to the city
where it's very crowded you can't have
children in the cities and so we're not
going to go back to the days of old
where you know
women had you know 10 children
half of them died and
so nobody cared because you had five
others
that's over now right now
if anything you get one
maybe if the woman is brave enough to go
through the pains they don't even want
to go through that so
so not only do we have manufacturing
that phased into services but with
services comes a new type of family
which is the single person nobody knows
everybody everybody's on his own
or like the three stooges once said you
know uh they said oh for one and one for
all
and kurt he says uh i'm for myself
everybody's for himself now okay that's
what it is more or less that's the
direction which we're going
okay here's another comment
well says your trade pyramid i talked
about that a little while ago model is
missing the most important the trade of
the money
where did you put the money trade
money trade what the hell is the money
trade there is no such thing as money
trade all we do is trade what you see
there you
change services for gadgets gadgets for
food and food for services and so on
that's it
that's all you trade
what money is is one of those three in
stored value
okay that's what money is money is just
a medium of exchange for one of those
things for the
one of those uh
groups for the other that's all it is so
when uh when you sell something
well uh someone buys it and he gives you
money but where did he get the money
well he had to sell something and he
sold one of those three to get that
money
so money has just stored value
but all you have is one of those three
that's what we're trading
so there is no such thing as trade in
money okay
again don't get confused with this thing
where today people are investing in uh
bitcoins and so on you know uh
that's uh again where did they get the
money what does the money represent
okay
and they say well it represents value
where did you get that value well you
got it either for providing a service
uh providing a
a good
or maybe food
which is another tangible good right
so it's uh trade is only one of those
three there's no other thing except
those three
okay here's uh now the file says
talks two guys in fact uh one guy says
the cubans were responsible for jfk's
death and rightly on he was trying to
kill castro after all another fellow
says jfk was shot at from multiple
shooters at different angles this was
and is standard military practice
okay well yeah yeah i'm as you know i'm
i think i'm a conspiracist one of those
nuts
uh yeah kennedy was murdered by the u.s
government specifically as i mentioned
the other day
i think the leaders of i mean there were
many people involved but
primarily inside the u.s government was
johnson lyndon johnson
j edgar hoover and
alan dulles
head of the fbi head of the cia head of
the u.s government before he was vice
president until you know kennedy was
dead so those three were the masterminds
uh the ones who pushed it the most and
they had a lot of conservative groups
uh in
washington dc that did not like the
kennedys at all they were too liberal
the the world wasn't ready for the
kennedys
[Laughter]
especially the united states they
weren't ready for the for for them and
so yeah all these conservatives
conservative especially you know the oil
men in texas and so on and the mafias
who were trying to
recover their properties in cuba you
know there were a lot of people who
hated the kennedys after all he was the
guy who won with the least
uh margin over nixon okay so
you know
they they didn't really want them in
fact uh as i understand it sam giancana
who is the
head of the chicago uh outfit uh either
him or his boss he was like number two
and uh the other fella was retiring or
whatever but gave him counsel uh more or
less like what happens in cuba today
where you have uh
castro in the background you know really
governing or giving suggestions
but sam giancana apparently uh mustered
the votes in illinois to go in favor of
kennedy
thinking that maybe by appeasing him you
know uh
bobby kennedy who was prosecuting all
these mafiosi uh would leave him alone
and that didn't happen and so they got
rid of kennedy
and a year later that that cost bobby
his job and in 68 it cost him his life
so yeah
that's how democracy works okay yeah
okay and here you have another guy it
says uh subject of homosexuality which
we touch upon as well because we want to
know whether
you know this has something to do with
the extinction especially my my argument
which is that um
it's in the cards that there will be
more and more homosexuals from now on
they're not
coming because of something they ate
they're not coming because of climate
change they're coming out of the wombs
like that because our we've been in
bring for so long and now we're in the
big cities
thousands of people inbreeding in there
you know and yeah whatever comes out is
not going to be very
uh sophisticated in their genes we're
all going to be more and more clones
and yeah we're going to be seeing
all kinds of genetic problems and i
think saying that this is a genetic
uh type of problem okay so what does
homosexuality even mean
is it being a limp wristed uh femboy
trying to understand how it differs from
a fetish
if an old-fashioned gruff
male is aroused by other males is that a
curable learned fetish whereas a girly
personality is an incurable uh innate uh
orientation orientation
and so
well this is my answer to this fellow
okay almost two hours let's define it
same-sex attraction doesn't mean you
have to go to bed with a guy but you're
attracted by men
in the case of men right women are
attracted by women okay so that's my
definition of that same sex attraction
now uh the way i look at it there's only
two sexes and that's double x and x y
that's it you know there's no
intermediate
uh even if there's an exception out
there somewhere you know i'm not sure
what that thing is
as i understand it the
kamado dragon has
uh like a z in there okay
but uh the third sex in humans uh when
we talk about uh third sex you know lgbt
xyz all these other things and pronouns
well that's only politics okay that's
only because we're in the age of
diversity and inclusion right now you
know every university on the planet now
especially in the united states has
created this uh diversity and inclusion
department
which is incredible you know they have
this everywhere it's like it's a problem
and they want to make sure uh when you
go to college you're
safe okay that's a way of guaranteeing
it
okay anyways uh the way i look at sex is
only for reproduction
okay only for reproduction mother nature
did not make sex for enjoyment
for leisure
if you
enjoy it if you have fun with it more
power to you that's great and i'm sure
mother nature kind of insinuated that
in order to get you to do it
but the origin of sex there is uh
for the purposes first only for
reproduction that was the only purpose
and
the origin of sex is l-e-c-a
what the hell is l-e-c-a well here we
have a a little run-down on this
transition from prokaryote to
uh proto-eukarya to the less eukaryote
common ancestor okay
last you carry it common ancestor
l-e-c-a there you have it that's what it
is uh until conservation modification
and reconfiguration of pre-existing
genetic circuits via mutation horizontal
gene transfer
endosymbiosis and selection as detailed
in previous articles of this collection
okay during the course of this
evolutionary trajectory the
c e-l-e-c-a became
sexual
reasserting and recombining chromosomes
in a process that entails regulated
fusions of blah blah blah blah blah okay
so
the leca became sexual originally this
is the theory okay it doesn't mean you
have to believe it i'm just saying this
is uh probably the main theory out there
the ldca was sexual uh was sexual is no
longer a matter of speculation or debate
as evidence of sex and of genes
exclusively involved in meiosis has been
found in all major eukaryotic
radiations and they mentioned several
papers there that uh stand behind that
statement okay so they all apparently
all these people agree uh all these
researchers agree that um
the uh ldca was already
sexual
and
eukaryote is the um
the source of plants and animals
and so if you wonder why plants and
animals
have sex
well you have to trace it here
and so i'm going to ask you do you think
this uh original this ancient
uh eukaryote is uh
was that
thinking pleasure
how about plants do
do plants talk about pleasure do they
have pleasure when they have sex when
they throw their pollen at each other
hopefully to the right sex
throw it to the
guy who throws the pollen to the other
guy i don't know
okay so uh yeah
and by the way this is eukaryote okay uh
the organisms whose cells contain
nucleus and other membrane bound
organelles there is a wide range of
eukaryotic
organisms including all animals plants
fungi
uh
prote protists etc okay so yeah
the eukaryotes gave origin to plants and
animals okay and they're saying that our
predecessor the paris predecessor to
eukaryotes
ldcas uh they already had sex and this
is what uh they apparently discovered
after doing research apparently there is
quite a bit of unanimity to that
so
i don't know it's just a theory
but it sounds like a pretty good theory
to me because you have to wonder why
it's plants and animals that have sex
not all of them i guess i don't know
but
plants and animals uh essentially uh
reproduce through sex
and so sex was made for
uh not for pleasure because i can't
believe that plants have pleasure
with sex
you might say well
you know how do you know that well i
don't know that i mean i'm not a plant
i can't tell you they have uh uh sexual
pleasure out of throwing the pollen okay
i just have to think that a plant does
not have all these uh senses that humans
have for sure
and i don't even think they have the
senses of you know a starfish
so
i don't know what can i tell you sex was
not made for for pleasure
okay if you get pleasure that's like a
you know a bonus you know it's a
unwanted consequence but uh
sex was made for reproduction and you
cannot have reproduction between two
males you cannot have reproduction
between two females
end of story and of course uh
homosexuals will especially the lobby
you know homosexual lobby out there
they're gonna oppose that because you're
destroying their theory that you know
that
sex sexes for pleasure
and all they're doing is exercising
their right to pleasure
well you know i have a little bit of
problem with that because i'm saying
it's not for pleasure and you know that
tends to destroy their theory
okay uh here's a couple questions for
you to ponder until next time here okay
and it's uh extension questions that
i've got for you okay anyone who wants
to tackle them
well man live another thousand years
and you think uh humans will be around
for
next thousand years
how about a million years
okay
and again uh the one that i want to
focus on is the fact that for 200 000
years we've probably been on the planet
as human beings meaning that if we go
back in time the last uh person we could
still have sex
viable sex with
within our species would be maybe
anywhere from 200 to 300 000 years ago i
call that the origin of our species
somewhere around there okay
and so if for most of that time maybe 90
95 percent of that time
we were hunter-gatherers okay primarily
hunters uh and we were ten thousand
years
maybe about nine percent or so who knows
uh we were farmers agriculturalists
uh
0.1 percent of that
we were industrialist manufacturers
the
last 300 years maybe
and uh and now for the last what 50 60
years we've been
service providers
and now
we're not going back to manufacturing
we're not going back to agriculture
we're not going back to hunting
so what for the next thousand years for
the next million years
we're gonna be doing the same boring
things over and over again just doing
services
or maybe the robots take over which is
you know the next issue there uh will we
live
the next hundred years in
like the service economy
or leisure unemployment meaning the
robots do everything and we just have a
great time just watch tvs couch potatoes
maybe do the gym i don't know
is that what
we can expect for the next 100 200 300
years
you know uh
uh either unemployment meaning
meaning in a good way unemployment in a
good way that we don't have to work
because we have the robots doing
everything for us and we have only this
service economy
uh and then the last one will we ever
have a world government
i mean here we have uh these three
empires the chinese the russian which
might merge
i don't think each one trusts each other
that's my take on that but right now
they have a common enemy which is the
united states and you know the enemy of
my enemy is my friend okay
and so we have these three empires will
there ever be a world government from
those three empires
will there come a time when all the
politicians shake hands and they say
okay let's let's all kiss and make up
and there are no more countries
no more religions
what was it john lennon no religion too
we all become one
we're just humans for the first time in
the in our history no more divisions
will that ever happen
okay anyways food for thought
uh i hope you tackle it
okay
let's get on with it um we have now uh
this issue about uh
the uh
is it the pendulum
okay what is a pendulum
and uh
did it make any difference i mean was
its discovery important
and i'm saying
it was a very important discovery okay
or
development that they started working on
the pendulum okay
but before we get to that i gotta go
uh with the uh
what we left off the other days last
couple times which is this energy deal
because a lot of
the folks out there
you know apparently they they think uh
they still haven't learned a lesson what
energy is
and they just keep giving me the party
line they just put things that they copy
and paste that's all they know how to do
that this is what they learned by road
in
high school maybe college and they say
the same things over and over again they
go out there and just copy and paste
they say this is what energy is
and they don't attack the question they
don't address the issues that are being
placed before them
so they're skirting the issue of energy
and i can see why because they cannot
answer the questions then i'm asking
them they're not addressing my comments
okay and so this again for those people
who
have a little more intelligence than
some of these fellows okay for you to
ponder okay here it is val says
energy definition is what capacity
okay capacity that's what energy is
capacity to do work the definition of
capacity right to do work is what
conceptual
yeah capacity is a concept there is no
physical standalone object called
capacity
okay and as far as we know only objects
can move concepts cannot move
what does he say next says each form of
energy is explained as an entity that
can be
transferred
moved
so he's going to move the capacity
around then continues as a car battery
has capacity
okay so it has capacity great what does
it have it's as a concept
this is different than saying you know i
have a coin in my pocket that would be
having a thing in my pocket that would
be a thing right but if i say i have a
headache that's not a thing that i
possess
that's a development that's a that's a
verb that's going on in my brain okay so
having a headache is not the same thing
as having a coin in your pocket or
having uh money on your hands
dollar bills on your hand okay or a coin
in your hand
are we starting the car with a concept
well no we're starting the car with gas
gas is not a concept okay gas is a thing
as an object a thing
charged the battery will have more he
said mass
then when dead
well he's probably wrong he probably
meant weight because uh mass
you know i don't think he counted all
the atoms
in the battery
okay
uh what he did was weigh it okay he put
it on on uh
i mean how did he determine that the
battery had
uh difference between before and after
well he waited
okay so he put it on some kind of
device that measures its weight not its
mass mass is counting
okay you've got to count atoms to get to
mass it's the quantity of matter
are we measuring what is existing only
in thought as an idea but not having a
physical or concrete existence abstract
concept
there are only concepts or objects okay
he got one right the power of
elimination isn't complicated between
the two choices again very true
saying energy is a concept is completely
ridiculous
but he's saying it's capacity and then
he says that it's and he says that
capacity is a concept
and now he's saying that uh to say that
a concept is uh
you know that energy is a concept of
ridicule
so he's going around in circles and i'll
tell you why okay and it's that he
doesn't define the terms he's got to
define what an object is and what a
concept is he's got to tell us what the
difference between those two words is
before he can go around in circles like
he has here okay
in physics if you define a word that
that term is a concept okay if you
define it's a concept if you can point
to it then it's an object
and the question is can you point to
capacity
okay this should be a straightforward
issue any rational human being should be
able to deal with this and if you can't
well you're not a rational individual
you have a problem a mental problem you
you don't see you don't have to talk
about fizzy you need to see uh a shrink
okay
that's how simple it is straightforward
okay another fella says again they're
stuck on this energy thing
because he unlike this otherwise he says
you can point to
uh capacity okay but he's got a
different idea of what energy is he says
it's not he doesn't talk about capacity
okay he talks about a delta
okay we'll see what what this delta
thing is okay here is the process for
seeing the delta
okay i want to see it these are the
instructions i guess he he put in there
he says you take your film and splice
out your start frame okay i did that
took a frame
even though that's not the start of my
film of my complete film but that's
where i'm going to start my film no
problem i can have a film strip that's
going to be my first smell my first
frame of the film 505 okay
then overlay it on the end frame finally
shine the light through it and you're
now looking at the delta okay i called
it the 506 doesn't matter okay so i take
these two
i put one frame the 505 over the 506
which is what you see there and he calls
that the delta and he says now he can
point to the delta
or to the frame or to whatever
the question is um
will anyone on earth say oh yeah i know
what that is that's energy
uh one frame on top of the other and
that's
energy
or a delta letter d uh
greek letter d i guess right
is that what energy is with every person
on earth recognize and say oh okay i see
what he's saying he's talking about
energy
no i don't think they would no what you
need to do is
present a standalone object
a mock-up of it make it visible put it
on in the middle of the conference room
that's how we do it in science okay
and uh if you can't do that well you
don't have a uh
you don't have an object
so uh i you don't give instructions
on how to visualize energy you make a
drawing or take a snapshot or
take some silly putty and you know mold
it and you say this is energy this is
what it looks like
that's how it works okay that's an
object in science in religion you go
through all this stuff and religion
irrationality then you say let me let me
explain to you what energy is
now if you can define
energy it's a concept we don't define
tables we don't define chairs we don't
define dogs or trees we point to them
and say dog tree chair that's how you
present an object in physics not in
ordinary speech in physics okay so what
you have to do is bring energy put it in
front of us a little drawing picture
snapshot
statue
point to it and say
energy
that's all you want to see in here
okay then you have
pointed to energy right now you're going
through this rigmarole let me point to
the delta what is the delta will you put
one frame on top of the other and
no that's not that's not science that's
religion you're an irrational individual
okay
the way first again you got to know what
an object is for the purposes of science
an object is that which has shape
and yes if it has shape there should be
no reason for you to uh make a drawing
or a picture or a mock-up of it of some
kind and to point to it
and name it say you know tree and then
we know what a tree is you know you want
to
explain to or or identify an object for
um a uh an et you know klingon who comes
to visit us
and you say tree and say oh well what is
a tree and you say that's a tree you
point and you say tree
and now he knows what a tree is because
he sees it there he says okay the word
tree is associated with that thing he
pointed to
that's how simple it is and now you say
energy and you say oh what is energy
let me explain it to you first let me
define its capacity or the delta or who
knows what and then he says and see this
is the way you visualize you put one
frame on top of the other and then you
trying to light through it
and the guy said oh okay let me have a
beer now
okay uh
paul says mass and weight are two
distinctly different measures
uh-huh yeah they are uh but uh weight is
a measure mass is not a measure okay
mass you count
weight you measure okay
so waiting uh i'm sorry ma um
measuring and counting are not the same
things okay
can't you count 10 apples and you say
those are apples
okay how many apples 10
10 apples that's mass that's the notion
of mass
but if you weigh them the apples you say
okay they weigh uh i don't know 10
pounds or whatever they're big enough
so weighing is not the same thing as
counting
okay so mass is like counting apples
weighing is like putting them on a scale
of some kind and
getting a number in usually in terms of
pounds kilograms whatever
we can buy in mass measures of kilogram
uh gram well no we call it weight
uh
that's how we use it every day okay in
fact even the mathematicians use that
we can't buy in weight measures of
newtons of joules yeah nobody uses
newtons or jewels i don't even think
mathematicians deal too much with
newtons and joules again because they
don't really deal
with units of weight they talk about
mass
they
talk about kilograms and pounds in terms
of mass and what they're in the way they
determine that is through weighing
so so they're using the word mass to
refer to weight
that's what's happening and yeah the
units are kilograms and grams and so on
okay so we don't use joules or newtons
in fact uh
uh
when talking about energy you know we
used to use kevs killer electron volts
so
we don't use uh
some of these units
that are very specific to certain
industries and certain uh fields of
study okay those are very particular
people don't even know what a newton is
out there
they wouldn't even be able to define it
they don't have any idea the way it
works is everybody uses weight calls it
kilograms and the mathematicians want to
say that well that's really mass
but it turns out that the way they
determine that mass in kilograms is by
weight because kilogram is a weighing
type of
unit it's not a counting unit
okay
counting is one two three four five you
know five whatevers
five units okay how's that
so five units would be a notion of mass
but if you say kilogram weighing
you know you're talking about weight not
mass but the mathematicians called it
weight that's where the problem is
we can't subdivide grams into newtons
yeah they aren't the same kind of
measure okay you are using the word
weight as its common
definition the physics definition is a
different definition
it's interesting they say
you got the wrong definition but it
would be nice if they put the right
definition right and they never do that
they just say you got it wrong
okay so let's put it up there just so
that everybody knows if i get it right
or wrong this is the definition we use
okay here it is weight
mass multiplied by the acceleration due
to gravity okay
wait another one the force acting on the
object due to gravity okay apparently uh
weight has something to do with gravity
and what is mass well uh here's a paper
dating all the way to 1915
mass as quantity of matter
and you see another entry somewhere in
the internet i didn't put all these
references but mass is a way of
measuring the amount of matter
so what is weight well any body is acted
upon by the acceleration due to gravity
to get the value of the weight of the
body mass on the other hand the amount
of matter present in that particular
body
okay
and yeah that's the notion we have but
see we don't count atoms so we don't
know what the amount of matter is except
by weighing
that's where the problem comes in
and here you see it okay this is what
what we have you put uh
the balance
on the earth well then yeah what you do
is you're
looking at weight
mass multiplied by the acceleration of
gravity okay but that's how we determine
the way we determine all these things is
by weighing
okay we don't we don't determine mass by
counting atoms that's the bottom line
okay
okay so uh and what's missing there
again are the ropes but that's a
secondary issue first we need to
understand why mass and weight are
synonyms in mathematics
they are synonyms they are synonyms
because
uh
when you're talking about
something falling to earth
we call that weight
and the mathematicians call it mass
because they say well it's a measure of
the quantity of matter
but see
quantity of matter is not a measure
quantity of matter is counting
atoms or whatever units
whatever unit you want no problem you
choose the unit no problem but you
better count if you want to talk about
quantity of matter
quantity of matter is not measure
of matter measure of matter is weight
okay we measure weight we count
atoms or units for mass so
if you're going to
use the word mass to refer to
whatever gravity does to a body
then you're talking about weight
and what these people are talking saying
is we're going to call that mass
and so you have people like einstein who
goes in there and says you know if an
object accelerates near the speed of
light
it gains mass
so what it gained quantity of matter
because it sped that it gained more
atoms it became bigger and bigger and
bigger
because it gained more atoms
and they say no it's because of the
force with which it presses against the
scale
that's the notion right it's a
calculation but that's the notion
notions pressing harder and harder so
not gaining mass meaning you gain weight
because now you're having this thing
press against a scale that's a measure
of weight not of mass
mass is quantity of matter that means
that if
the object gained mass it became bigger
and if it just presses harder against
something it's the same ball but
pressing harder we call that weight but
the mathematicians called it mass and
that confuses everybody
that's where the problem starts and ends
okay and here you have mr eine einstein
he uh he came up with a principle of
equivalence he didn't understand why he
just said it seems like the you know
these two equations uh mass equals force
divided by acceleration which was
newton's second law i talked about that
in the past it wasn't probably not even
his but um and newton's gravitational
law again probably not his but he said
if you have these two situations they're
equal
okay a man falling from uh with uh his
elevator
and rising with the elevator at given uh
speed given acceleration well they feel
the same thing
and so he didn't understand why but he
said i'll call that the principle of
equivalence and what he was saying
essentially is that mass is equal to
weight because what is mass well mass if
if you use the mathematical formula okay
not what it is in physics but if you're
going to use a mathematical formula
force divided by acceleration okay what
do you have well if you set that equal
to newton's gravitational law well now
you have the principle of equivalence
okay
but uh you know what uh
einstein missed is that you know um
he never figured out the difference
between mass and weight just like all
these people because he was talking
about weight not about mass
he was talking about accelerating
something and pressing against the scale
he was talking about what you feel if
you fell
with your elevator or rose with your
elevator okay he said the feeling is the
same yeah feeling we don't care because
there are no observers in science
but the issue here was that
he was equating these two equations
right he's saying that the first
equation is equal to the second equation
they do this all the time
and
he didn't realize that was he was
essentially saying his mass and weight
are the same thing
okay that's what it came down to but you
know the mathematicians don't pick up on
this and in great measure because they
use the word mass to refer to weight
that's the whole problem
you know they're talking about weight
and they caught mass okay let's move on
to uh the
uh
what is it the
pendulum and um
this has a lot to do with what we just
talked about because pendulum is a
gravitational device
and it takes this
potential energy whatever that is and
turns it into kinetic energy whatever
that is okay we don't know what energy
is but one is transformed into the other
that's essentially what happens with a
pendulum okay
and so uh it all starts around uh the uh
17th century
so-called
scientific revolution
i call it the un
scientific revolution okay so let's
start with that
and here it is an unscientific
revolution
the first casualty was aristotle that's
uh
the
unscientific revolution essentially
killed aristotle okay so rest in peace
you know
and uh
uh he he died and then uh what happened
was they started doing experiments they
said well we can't do it dearest italian
way of saying oh let me do a thought
experiment which was later on
resuscitated by mr einstein right he
said they they used to do these uh
thought experiments and you know they
got a lot of those wrong
and that's why all these people
criticized aristotle says you should
have done experiments real experiments
on these things on the simple things
right
like throwing two stones and one big one
small and finding out they hit the floor
at the same time that sort of thing okay
so they started doing experiments okay
actually it started really in the 16th
century so it's to say that it was the
17th century revolute scientific
revolution uh i would say that started
already in the 16th century because you
had and i mentioned some names the other
day uh
who was it molete
steven gilbert just a few names there
but there were a lot more people you
know these weren't the only three
inhabitants in those states there were a
lot of people out there doing
experiments especially with things
that aristotle should have done like you
know throwing two stones a lot of people
did that experiment
and it got around
again i talked about that in the past
but uh 16th century you had like gilbert
he he played with magnets and so on so a
lot of people were doing experiments
already
okay but 17th century really is where it
took off and where you have all these
mathematicians come into play and they
started analyzing these things and
mathematizing them quantifying them
that's where the change in the 17th
century came in okay
so you have a rapid evolution of math
okay
uh emphasis on observing controlled
experiment no longer was it a casually
observing something now you deliberately
created an experiment and you say okay
let's and you started controlling all
the factors that could influence your
experiment
and so
experimentation improved significantly
in the 17th century in that sense you
can say it's an experimental revolution
not so much a scientific revolution
because experiments have nothing to do
with science let me repeat that because
people say well you you misspoke no no
experiments have nothing to do with
science mathematics has nothing to do
with science
science is about explaining
an experiment is not an explanation math
is a description okay so
let's get it right
science
is
explaining something mechanism
especially in relation to physics
physics is about explaining mechanisms
that's what physics is about that's what
the mathematicians who don't explain
anything rationally
they dismiss that as philosophy
okay they say
physics is math and experiment
that's that's essentially what came out
of uh people like galileo especially
okay
and uh so they established quantitative
relationships uh in experiments and uh
again it was an issue a fight between
descriptions and explanations what is an
explanation physical interpretation
mechanism that's what uh physics is
about and that's why they stop that's
why i don't call it a scientific
revolution if anything we got
sidetracked we went on a tangent and
started doing math and experiments and
forgetting completely about explanations
okay about mechanisms
and here's galileo's uh take on that
it just
puts it in the right context okay
philosophy
uh
natural philosophy right that he was
referring to physics is written in the
great book whichever is before our eyes
i mean the universe but we cannot
understand it if we do not first learn
the language and grasp the symbols in
which it is written the book is written
in what
mathematical language
and the symbols are triangles circles
and other geometrical figures without
whose help it is impossible to
comprehend a single word of it without
which one wanders in vain through a
dark labyrinth
and these are all statements of his
mathematics is the language in which god
has written the universe and believe me
if i were again beginning my studies i
should follow the advice of plato and
start with mathematics
i think that in the discussion of
natural problems we ought to begin not
with script with the scriptures
now you see why they put them in prison
right but with experiments and
demonstrations
so you can see uh what happened here we
had this man
and he was one of the first to propose
that
math and experiments
is what it's all about
and
you're going to see that with a pendulum
especially you know we do lots of
experiments and they still cannot
explain
the mechanism of a pendulum i mean what
is a pendulum is this uh here
that's pendulum my magic one
i mean how difficult can it be you know
here just a little stick moving back and
forth maybe with a plum bob at the end
yeah we know everything about him as far
as the description how fast it goes
this and this and that we know
everything about the pendulum except why
what causes it to move
and this comes all the way from galileo
galileo saying it's all math and
experiments that's science that's
physics
and he forgot about the explanations
about the causes the mechanisms what
causes all these things to to move out
there how does mother nature do all
these magic tricks that's what we forgot
okay
that's what we sidestep
and
what they were looking at with a
pendulum was this thing about the inside
track you have the earth going around
the sun and you have um what is it mars
going around the sun
and so they figured out well if you're
on the inside track you know you got a
shorter orbit
well you're going to go faster than guy
who's got to go long time around
so galileo you know they they sensed
this intuitively he didn't need to be a
genius to know this but of course a lot
of people were so ignorant in those days
that these guys were geniuses in
comparison to them
so you have people like galileo they
stood up because they said oh you know i
think the earth goes faster than mars
well no kidding
yeah because once on the inside track
the other one's on the outside track
and so
this is how they came out with this
experiment with the
with the pendulum because it gave them
an insight into this this is what they
were trying to get to they were trying
to look at how the planets moved
remember galileo had a one of the first
to use a telescope
uh in a
way that he could observe things that he
could later describe to the masses out
there
uh and you know he was the one-eyed in
the land of the blind
and so
he looked at the
galilean moons of jupiter the four moons
right
and
he he discovered things discovered like
i'm you know like
like columbus discovered america
did columbus explain america did he uh
invent america no he just bumped into it
and called i discovered america
and even that should be a challenge
but galileo's similar you know he just
looked and said oh i found four moons of
jupiter he couldn't explain anything
and then he found a pendulum he started
working with those he says oh here's the
pendulum i can describe it for you again
i have all the relations
yeah but you don't know why it moves
like that what causes it to move like
that that's that's where he failed
that's why it wasn't science because
that's what physics is about explaining
the causes why the causes why it behaves
that way okay what's causing it to
behave that way
okay
so um he he uh galileo began playing
around with um
pendulums as early as 1602.
you know he was still quite young in
those days he was about to enter the or
i think he had already entered the yeah
he had already entered uh as a professor
at the university of padua
and so he started running this
experiment with
pendulums and he said look
it's so strange because you know
if you look at the amplitude
of two pendulums going side by side
and one has a short amplitude the other
one has a long amplitude they still move
at the same time
so they keep time in the same way as
long as the weight and the string length
is the same
you know if you if you let go of them
one has a a greater angle
it'll move faster than the other one but
they'll all
they'll both be synchronized
and so he didn't answer why he just it
is so
so it's different to say it is so and to
tell you why how come
okay so let's distinguish those two
things
okay he went in there and he said well
what if i replaced uh these two
uh
you know these two angles and i just
make them the same angle but i change
the weight and so now he put
more weight on one side and less weight
on the other in this case we're
illustrating that with two
balls versus one ball okay
and you can see they even though the
angle is the same
the um the the rate is
is
almost exactly light in fact it should
be exactly like if if you knew the exact
weights of all these things right
and they had the same distance and so on
okay so you say okay it's strange that
sounds
that you would think that the
heavier weights would move slower right
and that wasn't the case they moved
exactly at the same rate
okay so what was next well he said what
if he changed the string length and so
now they change the string length and
now they did
notice something very strange now that
did change for the first time
you know the the rate at which they
oscillated
and so they said okay the weight doesn't
change it
and the angle doesn't change the
amplitude doesn't change it but
apparently the string length does
okay
okay so he had a description
he looked at that that's just intuition
that's what he sees in front of it you
know observer stuff
gawking
and you just describe what you see and
you get a noble prize you know i get the
nobel prize in pendulums why because i
was the one who discovered
that the amplitude and the weight
doesn't change anything what changes
uh the rate is the length of the string
okay so he gets 100 points for that and
uh
so he should get an oval for that for
discovering uh something about the
pendulum a description about the
pendulum
is that what science is about is that
what physics is about bumping into the
wall say hi i discovered the wall
well yeah you
you still have the paint on your nose
i'm the one who discovered the wall i
get a nobel prize for the wall because
i'm the discoverer and i i mathematize
it i can tell you at what speed i hit
the wall how big it was you know you can
describe it any way you want
you get a noble for this for describing
okay but
um we went on to this uh well he went on
to this uh galileo
uh used his knowledge his extensive
knowledge of pendulums to create
the pendulum clock he's probably yeah he
well he didn't create it he designed it
gave it to his son who died a few years
later died prematurely more or less and
his son was constructing this device
when he died before he was
able to finish it but they have
constructed it today and this is what it
looks like so if you want to see how it
worked it works more or less like this
there it is okay
and you can see each one of those tick
marks okay
is caused by the pendulum swinging back
and forth
okay so this was uh what galileo had in
mind this is what he invented
uh is this science
or are we talking about uh technology
here
so yeah
galileo
observed and because of that because
observed without understanding anything
of the causes the whys the mechanisms he
was able to build a device no we call
this technology so he developed
technology based on description but so
far we have no understanding of why the
pendulum goes back and forth
and yeah this is by the way this is a
gravitational clock and just in case you
didn't notice let me make that
specifically clear okay you can see this
moving back and forth okay
uh but while it moves back and forth
you see that the weight is falling so i
put it in fast motion just so you would
see that okay you see how it's uh
dropping the weight that's there that's
what's driving the mechanism okay if you
didn't have that weight there you would
not have uh perpetual motion
okay so if you think that it's gravity
moving that and then moves forever well
no it's it's got something that allows
it to move and in this case it's that
weight which is a
weight thing not a mass thing it's got
nothing to do with mass it's got to do
with weight meaning the force of gravity
okay so it's a gravitational clock by
the way okay just wanted people to be
aware of that
okay so and uh by the way uh christian
huygens uh later on he was
1665
1665 he
uh made the first really
practical uh
pendulum clock
okay and from there you know again time
was very closely associated with the
pendulum they wanted to control time and
here was one of the first devices that
really were they were able to or you
could say the first clock right that in
which they were able to really
measure time to
any
measure of accuracy okay
it was the pendulum clock this this was
the real before that they had water
clocks and clip syndras
[Laughter]
you know the drop of water
and they replaced that with uh the
pendulum clock which was a little more
controlled and of course from then on uh
clocks were
improved over time you know
and by the time you get to the
19th century you have this fellow and he
uses this pendulum uh to
tell you that the earth is rotating okay
that's occult
and uh
you know what you see is that the
the uh sweeping
of that pendulum uh changes angles uh
simply because the earth rotates
okay so he was able to show that without
staying outside of the earth being
inside the earth you could show that the
earth rotates with this little device
okay what did they all miss
uh from phone call
before and fo qual
onwards all of them what did they all
miss this is what uh galileo missed okay
this uh this was the cause
we're gonna put the cause
of the pendulum what causes the pendulum
to behave the way it does okay and there
you see it okay we put it on top of the
earth okay galileo there with his two
little uh pendulums well every atom of
each one of those pendulums is attached
to every atom on earth i just put the
one the main ones because that goes to
the center of the earth which is the
center of gravity of our planet it's a
sphere okay this also shows that it's
got to be a sphere otherwise the
pendulum wouldn't work
and uh and yes if every atom of the
pendulum is attached to every atom on
earth specif and stronger as you move
towards the center well then yes uh this
is the reason that there's a physical
influence from the earth on those two
pendulums okay so this is what they
missed what they missed is the ropes the
stuff that they could not see or touch
and clearly you're not going to be able
to
discover
the ropes to see your touch
you know you can't see or touch the
ropes okay here here here again you know
i say pencil let go of it falls to the
earth
again repeatable you always have to make
it repeatable for it to be scientific
right so we do it at least two times
that's called repeatable also falls to
the earth i guess i proved my point okay
but the issue is there's nothing here
and there's nothing here
other than air right but i mean air is
not
uh
it's not air that causes gravity okay so
what what is pulling what is pushing on
the pencil what came in contact with the
pencil
okay and the same with the pendulum i
mean if you had the pendulum moving back
and forth i don't want to hypnotize you
but you know if you move this back and
forth
why does it why does it cling and move
back and forth
well again because every atom of that
pendulum is stuck to every atom on earth
primarily towards the center is the
strongest
force right
and so yeah it moves and it comes back
because it's trying to get to that
center
and eventually if you let it stay there
for two hours
it'll stand there and point to the
center of the earth
see how simple it was
and the only way you're going to figure
that out is if every atom of the
pendulum is tied bound to every atom on
earth
if it's not physically bound why would
it point in the direction of the center
of the earth
and why would it eventually stop at that
point right
after swinging
and then the other issue is
if if you don't explain it with
some kind of pull some kind of
attachment in this case uh
every atom being connected to every atom
on earth
of the pencil right
what are you gonna put in there spirits
uh energy is that what we're going to
put in there we're going to call it the
mass
what is the mass
oh yeah that's right we determine mass
by weighing
okay
uh
let's move on to some of the questions
and comments people made
since last time here they are first one
and
file says
and it goes with what we're saying here
right
uh what we've been talking about last
few minutes uh says
let me get this bigger here if an
adjective is somehow transformed into a
concept because it is composed out of
other objects then the rope hypothesis
is false because the ropes are a concept
because they are made out of threads
first of all there's nothing false in
science
false is a
true right are words that belong
exclusively to religion false and true
true or false
those are opinions opinions belong to
religion that's what religion is
opinions
uh you know
beliefs
here we're not talking about religion
we're not talking about opinions or
belief we're not talking about true or
false we're not giving you an opinion
what we're saying is that an object
is that which has shape
now he says
well
the rope is made of two threads
therefore it's made of
something that is made of two objects is
a concept
well here we have a table it's made out
of but five pieces at least i would say
you have four legs
and a
top
a board
so
a table is not an object because it's
made of five objects
how about a dog it's got a head four
legs a tail body
you have at least six there
and we could go on and on he's got a
heart
liver you know
dog is not an object because it's made
of all these parts
and how about the rope well the rope is
made of two threads she says but no
here let me show you
a rope
that is made of
one thread
okay this is a single thread
we have a single thread okay
make sure you understand that let me
move this out of here for a second
okay here you have it okay it's a single
thread closed looped
and then you have the rope
so
a rope is made out of a single object
and a rope is a single object
yes or no
but uh yeah there's a single closed loop
thread in all of space in that sense the
rope is made of a single object it's the
same uh you know we call when the
magnetic thread you on the
electric thread just
for the sake of explaining how
you know just to relate to the famous
the
ubiquitous
uh transfer swap which has a magnetic
field in the electric field we use the
same word we say the electric thread
magnetic thread thread there's no
difference between the two threads
it's a single thread in the entire
universe okay it's just coming around
that region where we're connecting two
atoms that's all it is okay
but uh but the point here is that when
you look at a table you don't say well
what is it made out of how many parts is
it made out of you're not thinking about
that you're looking at the table and
thinking it's made out of a single piece
the same as the dog when i point to a
dog you're not saying well how many legs
does it have or oh but it's made out of
different parts
no no you point to the dog and say that
whole thing is called the dog the whole
thing the whole system is called the dog
and the same for a robe you know you
point to this i don't care if it ends
here you know
you point to this whole thing you say
this is a rope this is the word we use
to
refer to this device this entity this
thing
so we point and say rope
okay and that's how you're supposed to
present
uh
energy for example
you should point i don't care if it's
made out of a gazillion particles fine
i don't care about that i'm looking at
the overall shape of this thing you call
energy or this whatever you call it mass
uh field we're looking at the whole
thing is it a physical object you say
yes okay just point to the whole thing
say well it's made out of all these
particles i don't care
we don't care about what it's made out
of okay
but if you use it like that that's where
you run into trouble okay
for example the ether you know
what is the ether well you can point to
it and say it's this blob that's the
ether okay fine no problem we take it as
if it's made out of a single piece we
don't care
but you say well see it's made out of
all these particles because they're
going to vibrate
oh now you're not talking about the
ether the whole blob now you're talking
about a portion
the heart the liver
of the ether now you're pulling a piece
of the
ether out of there and doing something
with it
okay so the ether is the whole blob
you can't say well but i'm going to be
using only this portion we'll call i'm
going to call that the ether
no no that's called the
subportion of ether
and yeah then that means you're treating
it as what it's made out of and not as
the ether when i use a rope i'm saying
you know what it does as a rope
and in the case of magnetism i separate
the ropes and i call them threads now
i'm going to deal with the thread but in
all cases i'm dealing with an object
and they can't do that with
for certain with energy especially they
define it as the capacity
okay here you have uh
another comment paul says about aim rand
some caller ein rand i call her a night
and entity is a thing
now i don't know if he was uh a parody
ain't here or whether this is what he
truly
believes in or proposes theorizes and it
doesn't matter because i'm going to
address the issue okay so i don't care
if he believes or or was just
regurgitating hi and there okay and it
is a thing a solid thing that is only
this matter state air is not an entity
and not a thing not an entity fluids are
not entities and yeah this is what eins
said
uh she said these things
so whether this agrees with her or not i
don't know but this is what she said
she she uh concluded all these fluids
air that's those are not things those
are not entities the word that she was
analyzing okay
entity is what it what is given in sense
perception
again if entity is a thing
an object
something then it has nothing at all to
do with perception meaning ain't
never figured it out
she did not figure it out she made all
the errors that everybody else made
okay uh hume can't always made the same
error wittgenstein all of them made
exactly the same error they never
figured out what an object is
okay
never have we had a definition of the
word object thing
for the purposes of physics
and people say well she was doing
philosophy well no uh the thing here is
that uh this is not about uh
whether you
are doing philosophy or something else
what we're talking about here is that um
if you're going to be doing physics okay
you're going to be doing physique if
you're going to be doing science then
you're going to have to use
definitions that are universal you can't
say well no i defined it for this
you can't chop that off like that either
you do science
or you do what mr rutherford says you do
stamp collecting
so uh
maybe she was doing stamp collecting
okay we don't care that
but if she's gonna try to rationalize
something she's
across the line into science she's
crossed the line into physics now she's
gonna abide by the rules of physics she
can't say well i was doing it for
philosophy sorry philosophy is part of
science and if you're going to do
science we can only use one word the
word object belongs to physics not the
philosophy
it doesn't belong to this thing they
call ontology or whatever they call it
out there
in that world
we don't care about any of that okay in
science
and philosophy and physics are the two
branches of science in science an object
has only one definition and it's a
synonym of entity something body thing
etc
so there's only one definition and she
didn't figure that definition out
she can't say well i'm going to do it
for philosophy and it's got to do with
perception
no because perception has too many
problems and here are some of the
problems that uh she has with perception
and her notion of the definition of
object of thing of entity and here they
are entity thing are synonyms first of
all so if she didn't realize that well
uh we got a problem and so she can't say
that entity is a thing no because that's
like saying entity is an entity if
there's synonyms she can't use the word
thing to define the word entity but then
air and fluids are made out of atoms
hopefully they are things hopefully they
are entities hopefully they are objects
as bad as that might sound to your ear
yes air and
any water etc they're all objects
physical objects because anything made
out of atoms had better be an object
okay not that that's the definition of
objects but anything that is made of
atoms had better be an object
okay concepts are not made of atoms
and um perception well that's for sure
uh no go you know it doesn't prosper why
because first you need nouns before
verbs perception is a verb
and experiment that's what she's doing
there by perceiving you're saying well
until i perceive it's not an object it's
not a thing
and so no that's not the way it works
and that's why we do not accept
observers in science there are no
observers we do not care what you feel
what you sense because that comes
afterwards
objects are defined are pointed to right
or determined before you do any
perception
and
perception requires two objects
okay that's the other issue you need uh
two objects to make
one object one entity
and then according to her definition and
an object requires no motion object is a
static concept so there had better be no
motion meaning no verb meaning no
perception okay perception requires
motion
no object requires perception
okay uh another fellow says
i think the same thought
talking about the same subject really
here uh to limit yourself to defining an
object only that which has shape is
randian
i don't know where he got that because
that's that's not what she said
she said that and much more meaning she
did not know what an object is because
he you when you mention a lot of things
in in your definition means you don't
understand
if you say well an object is that which
i can touch and see which has shape
which has mass which has volume that's
not the definition of object the
definition object is chopped off at
shape all the rest of the garbage is
wiped out
and if you're going to say well an
object's this this and this and that
like ain't said
then she's got a problem and she did not
understand what an object is for the
purposes of science
and philosophy is part of science you
can't say well i'm going to do
philosophy and not science well sorry
philosophy is part of science you're not
part of science
you cannot and therefore you do not want
to define the implication of the word
shape in your definition
that which i say
okay
in your opinion fundamental to your
proposal of rational science but if it
is but if it is fundamental try to be
exhaustive and complete
well i think i am completely complete
that which i shade that's the definition
of the word object
and he says well you're not being
complete because i don't know what a
shape is
okay let's find out let's find out where
this fellow
is uh
pissing out of the pot okay here it is
uh in science we do not define any word
in the dictionary especially to please
the devil's advocate because
if
if that is
if an object is that which has shape why
didn't you ask me what the word that
means or what the word
is
uh or or the word which
or or or and i mean you can grab me nuts
asking me to define every word in the
dictionary why did you pick on the word
shape
and so yeah we do not define any every
word in the dictionary
and the only words we define are those
that make or break our theory and we
need to define the word object not the
word shape we do not have any reason to
define the word shape and here's the
reason why it's the context the context
of the word shape is we require a
definition of object because we can't do
physics without objects you cannot
explain a mechanism if you don't have
objects in fact if you had no objects in
the universe there would be nothing to
explain okay because there would be
nothing out there nothing happening
there would be no physics so you need
objects to begin to do physics that's
the first word of physics
we have to choose a criterion that's
what this context is about we either go
with seed touch which is the religion of
mathematics that's what they use or with
shape
okay and so
the question here is uh
the choice are we going to choose c
touch or are we going to choose shape
do we need to know what c touch is to
infinitesimal degrees do we have a have
a perfect definition of c touch no we
don't we can say look c touch the normal
definitions normal notions of those give
us an idea whether we're going to go
with c touch on the one hand or shape on
the other
every object in the universe has shape
not every object in the newer universe
can be seen or touched we're done aside
from the fact that c touch are verbs
shape is an adjective okay shape is a
property of all objects see touch is
something that they do you have to
define nouns before you define verbs
so that's the issue do we need to know
what shape is well we don't and so if
you have trouble with that then that's
there's the corollary if you don't
understand the meaning of the word shape
please take kindergarten 101 again
okay
i mean every little kid can teach you
what shape is
so yeah it's all these devil's advocates
extreme devil advocates they say well
you need to define shape
well not in science science we don't
define shape because it's not a key word
not at all what we need to know is the
difference between shape
on the one hand and c touch on the other
because if you do not go with shape
are you going to go back to c touch
is that the default are we going to
continue with c touch like we have for
the last 10 000 years on the basis of i
don't know authority democracy
tradition
is that what it's all about
or are we going to say no we we had the
wrong definitions for the last 10 000
years and we're going to challenge it
we're going to challenge it we're going
to replace it with shape because shape
is universal
it's a static concept it's an adjective
not a verb therefore you do not have to
go in there and uh run any test or move
anything shape is a static concept okay
and yes it's a
in in religion it's no or ordinary
speech it's known as a noun in physics
it's known as an adjective it's a
property it's it's a characteristic of
an object okay
and uh yeah we have to destroy this
notion that an object is that which we
can see and touch which is also by the
way the definition they use for exist if
you can see or touch it
it exists but if you can't see or touch
it it doesn't exist so we can't see or
touch the ropes
right
that
cause this thing to fall the earth and
because of that
there's nothing there that doesn't exist
that's the way they
reason it okay so yeah we can't keep
using see and touch for both object and
for exist that's what's got to die
okay another foul raises a similar issue
says when you give a definition of
something
you are giving your opinion of that
thing
what is that so
that is it is subjective
okay
then you take it for granted that your
opinions are not opinions but objective
thoughts that are valid for everyone so
everybody's got to buy into it or you
know they're unscientific that's what it
what he's saying then i'm accusing them
of this okay
you don't go very far in having your
philosophical proposals discussed
big accusations
well uh no see mine are not
okay mine are not opinions i'm defining
the word object for example and i'm
saying an object is that which i shape
that's a definition you might say well
that's your opinion
okay the way it works in science
and again this is this is in science
okay
the way it works in science is that you
either
get in the ring and challenge the
definition by putting another definition
we can live with okay
or you keep your mouth shut
you accept it so it's not that i'm
giving your opinion or that i'm shoving
it down your throat
the way it works is if you got a better
mouse trap you have to get inside the
ring and fight
for your mouse trap
only one definition can remain standing
we don't have two champions
in uh in boxing or or in sometimes in
boxing you do but in in science
in physics you can't have two
definitions for the same word one of
them can only stand
and so if you've got a better definition
you get inside the ring we fight
you put on your put on put up your dukes
put in your gloves and put up your dukes
we fight and only one man remains
standing okay so if you get a better
definition get inside the ring and fight
for your definition defend it if you
can't defend it because it's trashed
like the seat touch is very easily
trashed
then you lost
lost uh you might say well that's your
opinion yeah we can only use rational
definitions in science what is a
rational definition one that can be used
consistently
okay and one where you don't convert a
uh a
concept into an object by the way okay
but anyways you got to fight for your
definition it's not an opinion it's a
definition
and you either challenge it or keep your
mouth shut and the way you challenge it
is you bring another definition one
that's better
and you allow that one to be criticized
as well
okay so yeah that's the way it works in
science
in science we don't vote for definitions
we don't raise our hands we don't go on
authority and we don't go by tradition
we don't care what 99 of humanity
believes or even almost a hundred
percent we don't care
it's whatever you can use consistently
that's a scientific definition
paul says telling people they live on a
spinning ball is the height of missing
of disinformation
i'm still trying to understand why you
think that water can curve and stick to
a spinning ball what is gravity
you know what is interesting is all
these flat earthers
they come in there and they always ask
the question how do you curve water
they always ask the question then they
never come back
to receive the punishment so they never
hear the answer
and so you give them an answer
and they never come back to here and
then they go to another side they say oh
how do you curve water how do you curb
water and they keep going from side to
side just saying the same thing they
never come here
to
say well bill at least you showed me how
to curve water
so yeah i do show what is it like the
gazillions time that i'm showing how to
curve water
around the planet and why the planet is
round meaning spherical
and why gravity works because only
because it is a sphere
and the guys never come come back they
never
listen to the answer they just put the
questions a hit and run they
they never come back and here it is okay
one more time i'm sorry to boil those
people who know the answer okay so here
it is okay
and you see that atom and it's connected
by ropes i just put these few lines
there to simulate the ropes uh you have
the atoms there every atom on the
surface of the earth and i'm just
showing the surface of the earth here
but every atom is enter is connected to
all others but here i'm showing one atom
connected to all these other atoms on
earth same here okay and one on the
bottom so they're all pointing towards
the center because they're all being
pulled towards the center and that not
only works for water but also for air
which is what i'm showing with that
outer layer there all the atoms that
comprise air are tied to every atom on
earth and of course they're going to go
towards the center of gravity that's
where most of the
ropes converge upon and that's why all
all
liquids and gases are
shaped as a shell
around the earth okay the spherical
earth there is no such thing as a flat
earth only flat heads people with little
mind with tiny minds
talk about
you know evidence
and say well what's the evidence and
even when they showed them the evidence
of like a picture from outer space they
say well that was tricked by the
astronauts by nasa you know and so on
now the way it works is what i show you
there gravity is a function of the
number of ropes that interconnect every
atom that comprises our system called
the earth including the liquids on its
surface including the gas called
air that surrounds it so all these are
uh covering the earth like a shell
and why because every atom why don't i
mean why don't those atoms start flying
away
and there's the answer the answer is all
atoms are physically interconnected by
ropes that's why they don't fly away
they have no place to fly away because
they're tugged towards the center of our
planet
okay so that's the answer if you want to
know how
water curves now you know
every drop
in the ocean is
in fact every not only every drop but
every atom that comprises every drop is
tugged towards the center of the earth
because all atoms are physically
interconnected physically you know you
have this rope connecting two atoms
that's what we have okay two atoms bound
by a rope so this one tank can't fly
away okay got it you think so good
okay another issue
again it's got to do with all this
energy stuff and things like that and
and objects and things and this file
says short question data as such may be
a concept but the ones and zeros on a
hard drive do have a physical
representation i don't know what a
physical representation is either it's a
physical or it's a representation it
can't be a physical representation
so you got to choose are we talking
about zeros and ones being stand-alone
physical objects or are they
representations meaning some kind of
abstract concept
and it's again these people go around in
circles and bite their own butts okay
we transfer
this information
so he he quotes he puts quotes around
transferring information why did he put
quotes i mean in physics it's literal
this is transfer you you want to
transfer a box like this one from your
right hand to your left hand you go
that's called transfer i transferred the
box the cube
that's the way it works that's now can
you do that with a zero and one well i
try to grab the zero and i can't grab it
because there's nothing there even the
one it's a concept i can't grab that so
how do you transfer a zero or a one
how do you transfer information i mean
how do i hold
the information in my hand i want to
hold it so that i can transfer it
literally physically
and i can't do that
and these people don't understand that
why because they don't define their
terms they're using words of ordinary
speech
that's why they have to put quotations
well you know what i mean i'm
transferring it oh you're transferring
yeah i'm transferring information
why did you put it in quotes
well because
he knows it's not an object and he's not
transferring it that's why we're talking
about physics here guys
physics it's literal this is transfer
left to right
that's called transfer okay
if not how does your youtube video work
what works through electricity not
through zeros and ones okay uh but
someday when you get to high school
you'll
figure it out you know they'll teach you
this yeah
the way computers work is it's all
electricities in there
uh
it's
atoms in case of the rope model we say
that they're all bound to each other
they're all merged all these electron
shells and they spin in situ and that's
electricity
so uh yeah that's how your computer
works because it has all these
atoms which are merged to each other in
long chains and they spin in situ
that's the physical mechanism of what
makes your computer run it doesn't run
with zeros and ones whatever those are i
mean
i've never seen a physical standalone
object called a zero or a one that could
push
or pull anything inside a computer
okay
yeah
but maybe you can show me one day
how a zero pushes something
okay and uh so here we have uh
uh phil says ideas ideas are very are
they infinite
okay because i say that
ideas are finite okay you don't have in
it in other words if you have a bag of
ideas
and it's like a bag of marbles you pull
the last one out and there's no more in
there i'm saying the ideas are not
infinite in that sense it's not a
bottomless pit okay a black hole
you always pull
pull ideas out of there i'm saying no
you don't especially ideas regarding um
manufacturing things
those ideas are probably more limited
than abstract ideas like relating to
programming or things that you can do
out there or concepts those are
uh
not infinite
in the sense that you can come up
eternally with more and more ideas i
don't think you can i think those are
limited as well but uh
it's his reasoning that's wrong that's
what i'm going to criticize here it says
do we have an unlimited number of ideas
since the universe is finite
listen to this the ideas will
consequently be finite
now he's mixing
physics
with uh
abstractions
he's saying that because i can think
uh or create
create again with quotations create
ideas invent ideas develop ideas
that's not the same thing as creating
something physical i discussed that the
other day right
but if the universe is finite or
infinite has nothing to do with the
ideas that come out of the brains of
people
okay people can come up with uh ideas
create ideas invent ideas irrespective
of if if they're in a you know
prison cell
you know you're in there you're in this
box you know
they say oh my ideas are limited because
the room is limited my ideas cannot go
beyond the room
uh well i discovered in prison that yeah
the ideas can go beyond the room believe
me i proved that
[Laughter]
so
just because the room in which i'm in
you know is is small doesn't mean my
ideas cannot go beyond that okay so it's
his reasoning that's wrong okay so
uh my dear god with some of these people
anyways with that i'll see you on
wednesday
i'll see you on wednesday bye bye